life is seasonal right there's these  Seasons that you have and I just look at  it that way more of a Continuum of  seasons and sometimes you're going to be  free  to go diving with your homies every day  and sometimes you have to  serious stare at your computer and then  you have to be kind of committed to your  family and you have to you're growing a  kid and you're you know you're watching  him grow and enjoying that and there's  just there are restrictions on the  seasonality and in within those  restrictions and tensions moments of  Transcendence come through so there can  be moments of transcendence in the wide  open escape and there can be moments of  transcendence within the seasonal  pressures that you're under and you  can't access everything all at once like  life is just not like that so the more  we can embrace the conditions that we're  in is probably better